this is dedicated to Keanu Reeves all
100 movie literally making it big yes we
aren't that is the name of the show I
know I just got excited
[Music]
welcome back to making a big the show
where I make giant food for my friends
and special guests today I've invited
Kelsey and Peach okay she's done some
cool stuff on BuzzFeed multiplayer you
might have seen her 100 baby challenge
it's really crazy and I thought it kind
of fun to invite her in dream of a giant
food challenge we could do together so
let's go meet her so Kelsey yeah oh well
I hope you're hungry today you do a lot
of crazy things on the internet and one
of them is this 100 baby challenge yeah
so it's a challenge in The Sims where
you have a matriarch who's like one
character and she supposed to have 100
different children all different parents
you have to have a different parent for
every kid okay she's tired she don't
okay well we're on our second matriarch
now Shar our first one has sadly passed
off oh my god so you know how you said
every single parent it has to be
different that gives me an idea
because you know how there's something
like a 7-layer dip right you see where
I'm going with this what if we did a 100
layer dip where every single layer was
different I see where you're going with
this it's gonna be a challenge to even
think of all the ingredients if I do it
I will probably have to ask for your
help if you're down to like help me out
cuz I would think it's like you know
it's almost like a game you know we're
gonna have to feel gods as a strategy to
it I've been training for this day
alright good well I'm gonna go
brainstorm maybe with the Tastee team
and then I was shopping and I'll see you
in like half a day but yeah all right
I need to make a 100 layer dip and I
need help thinking about all the 100 and
greens no sweets this is kind of like
savory tex-mex
Southwestern so if you have any idea
feel free to start yelling about okay so
yeah Oh
chorizo that's really hard yeah that's a
different that counts that jump run
ingredients needles
Cheetos Lay's I need more cheese really
unfortunately that's kinda gross okay no
okay I need one more can't end on
weenies guys I'm gonna go to the grocery
store and I'll be back in about six
hours so Oh God whoo guys I got the
stuff it's not like four hours in there
someone help me want the door to my car
Thanks
[Music]
we got all 100 ingredients oh man no
we're gonna cook all these things and
build this dip don't know what's gonna
happen but I'll see you guys back in the
studio so Kelsey is that what we're
putting it in we went to the pet store
wood we got an aquarium oh I have a
little game plan here this is a color
coded order from top to bottom of all
the ingredients they are sorted by a
category there's gonna be a narrative
story arc throughout this dip you get me
I love a narrative story arc all right
ready yeah all right let's do it
editor put the snapping sound effect
yeah we're ready to go we have spoons
and utensils to get all this food into
here okay this is the breakfast burrito
section what is the very first thing
we're putting in first up is potato
chips if you crush them so they get like
crashing like so they get more
compresses as a hundred later that's a
good point
that's 199 more to go corn chips yes all
right let's go
that was nice amazing
oh now we have cheese I'm a very cheesy
girl normally start with Gruyere yeah
Gouda
yes about the next breakfast sausage oh
you're cute spicy Italian sausage and
you're Italian right yes so it's just
like me that's what you were expecting
to be no but then again I like have
simulated babies as my job so
we're both Sorbo thin a weird world oh
yeah okay what do we got
it's I can't pronounce that Oh boss
kielbasa
it looks cool I kind of want to taste
one - oh I'm very sure let me shake it
yes a one for this time zombie brown
bean I guess for meat yellow bell pepper
Oh vegetables I like vegetables wow that
is really pretty nice I'm so glad I have
someone helping I reduce oh yes
sometimes it's on the show food and
talking to an audience that hopefully is
watching that how you doing so guys
thanks for watching I'm for tuning in to
see you bye the end make sure to stay
through the whole thing so we just
finished our breakfast burrito next up
is chicken salad so we begin with a
layer of romaine roommates like one of
my favorite salads because it's so
crunchy crunchy right there you go your
crunchy my crunchy lettuce that's so you
did a really good job with the order
here I played around Google Docs chicken
next how many chickens do you think that
is in this actually let's not do that's
kind of dark you're the one making a
hundred babies yeah someone doesn't make
it there seems there since okay there no
you watch black mirror don't you touch
of you know I don't watch climb here for
this exact reason this is where it might
get a little messy so we have chicken
salad I think using hands might be a
little weird maybe we got a spoon oh yes
a rubber spatula aha alright you do the
honors you're doing a great job
spreading in here thank you
I'm really trying to put my heart and
soul into the spreading you're also
putting your arm into it
yep I don't know if I have really had
much chicken salad in my life me neither
it's not like a CT ur choice when you
get sandwiches you know it's like on
there but no one really wants
good Wow way to make those chicken
salads tears well upset could we got
tomatoes tomatoes you're beautiful
you're like Keanu Reeves like how he
feels you're breathtaking breathtaking
this is dedicated to Keanu Reeves all
100 layers are for you corn corn all
right
avocado yes how do you think we could
buy with this how many houses yeah none
we live in California next is Parmesan
to finish off our chicken salad we want
to make it right what are you first
layer now we're going to move on to a
little bit more healthy salad cuz this
salad got a lot of cheese so what's
first on the list iceberg lettuce
amazing ooh this is my one of my least
favorite letter I hate this this one
tastes like water yep next up green
cabbage cabbage is a little better
kravitch yeah kravitch I like crab juice
why do they call it red cabbage it's
purple cabbage radishes radishes you're
gonna go like there's like coins you can
like make em rain this is me at like the
Barcade ma'am this is the Chuckie Cheese
yeah red pepper hummus this is possibly
the best hummus I'll just do like this
technique the the scoop and poop I think
we can smear the hummus is together okay
oh my oh my oh my
hold on me finish gloopy okay I'll let
you plea sorry that was too cuz I hit
there whoops oh mrs. Dunn is goat cheese
goat cheese and feta wait nice all yours
oh yeah that's good yeah all right let's
go whoo
all right next is cilantro uh-huh it's
launched about people Pamela
I like cilantro it tastes like soap to
me I tell people it's genetic they don't
believe me come on just do it for the
viewers I hate cilantro exactly I feel
like it's like when you feel a little
kid like yeah let it go
oh man that's gross a little bit it's
it's just like so tastes like ass mm-hmm
not good all right well I love you
converse yeah why don't you take a
little cleanse that palate hmm cool
we're a layer 31 we got through the
healthy salad I think it's time to bring
in the next wave of ingredients yeah
probably gonna get a lot more unhealthy
from here on we're done bean and cheese
Lynn let's do those beans yeah here we
go
so black beans pinto and red oh yeah oh
that's a lot next refried beans which is
I think it's like the previous three why
do they call the refried I'll look this
up later
yep someone knows and that someone isn't
on this set right now after that we're
gonna do
a type of cheese which one is that ox
occur Oh Oaxaca like cheese let's go
cotija cheese where do we just finish
our bean and cheese did yeah we did oh
how can you okay so now where should the
Thanksgiving dinner portions which is
always a class yeah but we're gonna
start with a caramelized onions
caramelized onions I love those
okay cooked mushrooms I had to grow into
love of mushroom at first I was like no
you're eating fungus there's something
wrong Dulli turkey like you know turkey
on Thanksgiving yes exactly just like
mom used to make
and honey ham like the ham you would
have at Thanksgiving is yes - slappy
yeah you got slapped the ham a little
bit makes a few good sounds like
something else
mashed potatoes oh yes you had a big
spoon over there Oh cornbread stuffing
rice it's like a wedding Oh
what area almost halfway I think you got
the last thing on top of your
Thanksgiving is spinach I didn't know
what to put okay I wanted something
green we're going in until I can Italian
sandwich territory salami pepperoni
necks yes we have ham again making
another debut appearance that was I
think honey based it was a different
type of yeah that's a layer 50
oh that's 50 that's 15 oh we're halfway
there yeah yeah I'm pretty tired to you
I'll take a break
yes yeah all right we don't make a drink
oh yeah okay so I'm gonna make some
layered drinks oh yes this is a 100
layer dip so I thought it could be fun
do some like blended stuff so take some
frozen mangos all right time to blend
all right good
so first layer it's mango oh yeah okay
what's next we're doing more berries
next texture looks so good oh that's
cool
all right that's layer number two last
one we're gonna go for a white banana
looking there coconut banana it's like
almost like ice cream oh wow pretty sure
people call that nice cream that is a
three layered drink for you and for me
so pretty
alright here we go Nancy straws you're
scared huh the mango is amazing
pull them enough everything I'm trying
refresh I feel revived alright well
we're gonna get back to it 50 more
layers to go we're gonna continue where
we left off
yes finishing the Italian sandwich
suctioned what do we have next three
cheese
can you explain what these cheese's
they're Havarti so we're gonna party
with Havarti Colby jack and pepper jack
next we'll have a sliced black olives
we have a layer of red onions and a
layer of white onions onions have layers
yes
just like our ogres yep universe
I love Shrek what are you doing at maths
whoop okay okay don't go you're much
better at this than I am
basil jalapeno that's not jalapenos
jalapeno spicy stuff no I can't handle
spicy for the life eight to flaming hot
cheetos and they start sweating no it's
not working the diced green chilies
fried stuff oh yes onions in french
fries here we go tastes good now we're
onto our buffalo chicken dip ah yes so
we have Q Tea Party chips followed by
more of the color orange great yes
that's the Buffalo it's orange all right
dude that was a bit of a stretch but I
bet it will taste good
after that we got pulled pork yes
get in there rotisserie chickens there's
a different type of chicken than the
chicken we put in earlier yes it's
different
history style and now it's blue cheese
and celery this is the weight there was
no buffalo sauce in this whole orange
the orange it's so now we are loaded
chili we're gonna start with a Mexican
cheese blend Oh in an Italian cheese
blend then Swiss and cheddar okay do you
have a giant spoon
there you go it is a lot of chili that's
amazing chili has no chill we're trying
to feed the layers yeah we're getting
close to the top the math may have may
or may not have been a little maybe we
got a little gung-ho at the top looks
like finish strong let's go tops I will
do the spread I'm spreading for this
challenge God can't be stopped
they're wonderful so now we are on to
the stuff my mom wouldn't buy for me as
a kid that looks good together
you want to explain that one it's
self-explanatory let's just put the
mirror not far so what's their first
thing up here fried onion dried onion
rings yeah oh I love pimento yeah
veggie cream cheese I'm gonna throw some
spinach artichoke dip in there two more
dissatisfying it's a big blue all the
things you just weren't allowed to have
I mean I would want that store but my
mom's like no that's not healthy it's
not good for you I mean you're wrong
this is marscapone okay so getting
really intense with it dips right now
it's good cream cheese
even more more white spread serious
white spreads I think that's enough
oh no that's are we done with the white
spreads that's good white spread I'm
tapped we are next onto the bruschetta
spread oh okay so did you know you
weren't allowed to have her shut up
no chives I love chives oh that's pretty
now blue tortilla chips
nice big corner there what it's these
are fried onion yeah they're different
they're not like the chip they're actual
onion actual fried onions for last
alright this baked potato section what
do we got right now let's change up the
color a little let's do the bacon oh
yeah this all needs to call scallions
eggs
sure tater salad okay good old-fashioned
American orange cheese unnatural
beautiful and then not the yellow one
but the white one too and then we're
gonna put in some nacho cheese yep
that's pretty cool all right it's like
soaking into I know the cheese is like
soaking in okay so I have our last
ingredients everybody's probably
wondering by now like where is the block
don't worry we have it under control
with classic where we have tortilla
chips one is a ranch flavored nicely
done
maybe we should have crushed up a bit
that's for hold it just like soaks up
the keys that's great sour cream sour
cream oh boy here we go again with the
white yeah it's a lot of weight at the
top it's okay alright Pico heck yeah
what the Supreme Champion the one we all
came here there you go
yeah for
look at her she's beauty and she's grace
Wow we'd actually like filled up great
level how did this happen I don't know
how did you do this good ad you're a
magician you're a magician put that on
you eat it eat it okay finishing touches
or just add some cheddar that doesn't
count
this wasn't counting so it's still 90
garnish garnish and the final touch
layer 100 parsley
100 whoa that is it 100 layer dip
beautiful I'm gonna go make some giant
chips to be with this oh yeah our giant
we call Shrek yeah Shrek see you back in
here with so many giant chips so this
it's a giant flour tortilla the ones
used like roll burritos and I like cut
them into a like triangle and then just
spray with some oil and love and bake it
until it's crispy but I ain't that oh
this is just a shovel okay okay cool
yeah you can try to dip a chip into it I
think it'll probably break you can try
and if it breaks I'll bail you out with
the with the shovel I think what this is
here for I'm like nervous the guest of
honor please as you will Oh Oh yep there
you go where did it go a little indents
oh I felt that
yeah there you go whoa all right I'll
put it place it on your chip here's you
have a fork I've got I just yep okay
we're gonna put it down okay this is
like a full plate of nachos you know one
scoop I see some corn nuts
[Music]
oh yeah so you can remember the one we
went through all Wow all right well um I
think this is a two-hander Cheers every
time you bite into it it's different
Oh past even my wildest dreams I don't
like an entire egg this is the joy of
the 100 row I keep eating and you keep
discovering new things the treasure is
the friends we've made along the way can
you finish this no well going through a
lot of food today yeah we did
don't want it to go to waste I have
hundreds of employees really hungry
thank you for joining us Thank You Brad
yeah great co-host made this possible
thank you Shrek we'll see you guys next
time
and we're gonna feed a lot of hungry
people peace out guys bye
[Music]
you
[Music]